[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi
19 octobre
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition l'ile-de-france centre de la
recherche nucléaire même si la région ne
compte aucune centrale nucléaire elle
est un territoire moteur sur le sujet
avec notamment la présence du
commissariat à l'énergie atomique sur le
plateau de saclay quel est le niveau de
sûreté des installations nucléaires
francilienne le point dans ce journal
et découvrir le centre de formation des
métiers du btp attrape l'établissement
ouvre ses portes au public jusqu'à
demain afin de présenter ces filières
environ 200 apprentis et stagiaires y
passent chaque année le bâtiment et les
travaux publics
un secteur qui recrute en ce moment et
puis c'est ce samedi à mantes la ville
le secours populaire des yvelines
organise son congrès départemental
il a lieu tous les deux ans et sert à
faire un bilan demande un tueur ainsi
qu'à renouveler les instances de
l'association pour en parler parce qu'à
leurs odier est notre invité secrétaire
général de la fédération à des yvelines
du secours populaire
mais avant de développer ses titres
séance extraordinaire du conseil
communautaire de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines les élus
doivent élire ce soir le nouveau
président ainsi que son exécutif
le vote se déroulera à bulletin secret
on connaîtra donc le nom du successeur
de michèle losier qui a dû démissionner
après avoir été désigné sénateur en
septembre dernier
il présidait saint quentin en yvelines
depuis 2014 sauf grande surprise
pressenti au poste jean michel fourgous
le maire d'elancourt a été choisi comme
candidat de la majorité de droite après
une primaire interne qui s'est déroulée
il ya quelques jours et dans l'actualité
aussi une grève à l'appel de l'ensemble
des syndicats de la poste ce midi une
cinquantaine de personnes s'est
rassemblée devant la direction
départementale située à guyancourt est
les différentes organisations syndicales
cgt sud ou france ouvrière dénonce des
pressions
elle cite le cas de vincent fournier la
direction lui reproche des prises de
parole dans des centres courrier désir
in ce délégué syndical a fait donc
l'objet d'une procédure qui pourrait
conduire jusqu'à un licenciement
on les écoute au micro de camille
lambert pour nous c'est une évidence
qu'on peut
rentré dans les cendres ça il ne
conteste pas mais évidemment discuter
avec nos collègues et parler avec eux
fin c'est l'essentiel de notre activité
c'est la liberté d'expression c'est la
base pour un syndicalisme on espère
peser du coup sûr la direction
départemental afin qu'elle
qu'elle renonce à cette procédure
disciplinaire ce que c'est une
possibilité qu'ils ont encore ce qui est
pas de suite et pas de convocation en
conseil de discipline et que ça s'arrête
là contacté par notre rédaction la
direction de la poste n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer
étant donné que l' enquête
administrative est en cours
quel est le niveau de la sûreté
nucléaire en ile-de-france le sujet est
évidemment sensible même si la région un
abrite sur son territoire aucune
centrale nucléaire elle reste un moteur
dans le domaine de la recherche
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire a
présenté ses résultats pour l'année 2016
et c'est loin d'être totalement
satisfaisant les détails de nicolas
kirillovitch bilan moyen pour la sûreté
nucléaire en ile-de-france selon l'asn
si la région ne dispose pas de centrales
sur son territoire de nombreuses
installations sont en revanche présents
pour la médecine le traitement des
déchets nucléaires ou encore la
recherche d'ailleurs l'asm pointe du
doigt dans son bilan 2016 l'une des
installations situées dans l'essonne le
cis bio une usine qui produit des
médicaments radiopharmaceutiques et qui
présentent des défauts d'exploitation
depuis plusieurs années c'est des
défauts de défaut de ringer finalement
des défauts d'application des procédures
qui manifestent des sans doute un des
défaillances d'organisation défaillance
dans la manière dont l'exploitant est
organisée pour conduire sur
l'installation
mauvais point aussi pour les
installations basées à
fontenay-aux-roses l'asn ne considère
pas le niveau de sûreté pleinement
satisfaisant sur place bilan favorable
en revanche pour le cea de saclay et
l'ensemble du nucléaire de proximité qui
concerne essentiellement le secteur
médical même si l'utilisation des
appareils radiologique peut être aussi
améliorée et les travailleurs qui ne se
protègent pas suffisamment ne sont pas
assez formés et utilisent à mauvais
escient parfois leurs appareils ne
sachant pas les régler pour optimiser
vraiment le compromis entre une
irradiation minimale et une qualité
d'image suffisante pour réaliser le
geste en 2016 l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire a effectué plus de 220
inspections sur site en ile de france
une quarantaine d'incidents mineurs lui
ont été signalés je vous le disais dans
les titres les métiers du
bâtiment recruter surtout son centre de
formation de trappes
ils cherchent des apprentis ans et ap
bts ou bac pro
l'établissement organise des journées
portes ouvertes jusqu'à demain camille
lambert nous amène à découvrir ces lieux
maçons peintres ou canalisateurs ici
tous les corps de métiers du bâtiment
sont réunis au coeur de la zone
d'activité de trappes elancourt le
centre de formation des métiers du btp
accueille chaque année environ 200
apprentis et stagiaires
parmi eux boubacar élèves depuis deux
ans on a pris beaucoup de sagesse et on
nous apprend d'un projet a fait la pente
aussi le cours des technologies beaucoup
de choses à respecter aussi
les jeunes sont acteurs il dessine et
mettre en place le chantier après avoir
eu des notions en technologie et en
lecture de plans on leur apprend
justement cette autonomie ça va
permettre aussi aux jeunes d'avoir un
peu plus confiance en lui et présenter
ses idées car sur un chantier tout le
monde a droit de s'exprimer
des connaissances mise en pratique en
entreprise durant leur formation les
élèves sont en alternance
l'établissement organise des journées
portes ouvertes pour faire découvrir son
offre et ses métiers souvent méconnus
mais nécessaire la main d'oeuvre vient
souvent a manqué malheureusement il ya
très peu de jeunes
qu'ils viennent dans le métier dans les
métiers du bâtiment on pense à des
métiers qui sont pas forcément dans
lesquels on travaille dans des
conditions qui sont pas forcément
plaisante et pourtant on a besoin
aujourd'hui professionnel l'année
dernière il y avait fait un petit con
façadier après j'ai demandé de faire
ainsi appelé par ils m'ont accepté
depuis que j'étais petite je voulais
faire la peinture le centre espère
recruter une cinquantaine de jeunes pour
compléter ses effectifs
il est à découvrir jusqu'au vendredi 20
octobre c'est un passage obligatoire
dans la vie du jeune français une
journée à défense et citoyenneté se
dérouler hier à versailles
elle replace l'ancien giap et des mises
en place en 1997 après la fin du service
national
trente six yvelinois y ont participé
hier au programme les traditionnelles
présentations des militaires et le test
de français et mais aussi une première
les participants ont pu assister à une
audience au tribunal de grande instance
de versailles et ensuite poser leurs
questions aux magistrats et vertu
pédagogique pour comprendre le
fonctionnement de l'état de droit
propos collectées par patrick jacques de
dixmude et axel weber toucher du doigt
le fonctionnement de notre justice le
prévenu qui se présente à son juge le
procureur qui lui adressent les
reproches et qui fait son réquisitoire
pour réclamer une peine et puis son
avocat qui prend sa défense le prévenu
qui a l'occasion de se défendre de
donner son point de vue sur la chose et
le juge finalement qui va délibérer en
son intime conviction avec ses
assesseurs
voilà bien le fonctionnement de cette
justice qui est expliqué aujourd'hui à
des jeunes qui avaient en moyenne autour
de 17 ans pour moi c'est une première
je trouvais ça plutôt intéressant
surtout aussi par exemple le greffier
comment il résumé un peu lisse comment
dire l'histoire présente 2
de la fère et
et ensuite comment ça se déroulait avec
les avocats qui défendent est
la cuisine est justement le tout le
déroulement
j'ai trouvé ça très intéressant est la
journée défense et citoyenneté s'est
terminée à la cci à versailles et bim et
les jeunes ont reçu un diplôme
symbolique qui leur permettra tout de
même de pouvoir passer à l'avenir tous
les examens d'état comme le baccalauréat
ou encore le permis de conduire en 2015
près de 26000 franciliens ont été suivis
par la pjj la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse
elle est chargée de l'ensemble des
questions qui relèvent de la justice des
mineurs dans les yvelines on compte cinq
sites dont celui situé à villepreux une
unité éducative d'activité de jour cette
semaine elle ouvrait ses portes
patrick jacques de dixmude et mélanie
poker à cette coiffeuse on travaille
l'image de soi une étape pour l'aide à
l'insertion l'une des missions de
l'unité éducative d'activité de jour de
villepreux
notre directeur interrégional monsieur
simon a souhaité il ya quelques années
que
la sete ce lieu de villepreux soit
rénové et réorienter vers un lieu
d'insertion mais spécifiquement en
prenant en compte l'ensemble de ce qu'on
appelle la santé au global c'est à dire
le bien-être 24 jeunes de 16 à 18 ans
peuvent être reçus en continu un
accompagnement individualisé proposé par
sept personnes dont trois éducateurs et
deux psychologues
je met en place des ateliers comme de la
boxe thérapeutique les ateliers de
relaxation
je peux aussi être avec mes collègues
sur des ateliers de valorisation de soi
sur les groupes des changes aussi qu'on
fait avec en partenariat avec une
éducatrice et photos langage de la vidéo
voilà et des espaces de parole par an
sais tu agis est l'un des cinq
établissements yvelinois de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
la pjj dépend du ministère de la justice
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
prend en charge effectivement des
mineurs délinquants mais prend également
en charge des mineurs sous protection
judiciaire des mineurs qui peuvent être
pris en charge en protection de
l'enfance et à ce titre nous travaillons
avec le conseil départemental qui est le
chef de file de la protection de
l'enfance actuellement la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse des yvelines
prend en charge environ 800 jeunes
l'europe vous aide t elle vraiment
question posée hier soir à l'occasion
d'un débat citoyen à saint germain en
laye il était à l'initiative de la
maison de l'europe des yvelines a été
abordé la thématique des fonds programme
européen d' aide aux agriculteurs et aux
entrepreneurs ainsi que de leur réelle
utilité
un rendez-vous en présence notamment de
la sénatrice des yvelines sophie primas
de la vice présidente du conseil
régional en charge des affaires
européennes stéphanie von euw ou encore
du représentant en france de la
commission européenne guillaume rôti l
accès internet est en très haut débit
dans la campagne yvelinoise c'est pour
2022 est la semaine dernière le
président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier ainsi que le pdg
groupe tdf olivier huart ont lancé le
déploiement du réseau fibre optique dans
les zones rurales c'était à l'hippodrome
de rambouillet nicolas dandrieu étaient
sur place aujourd'hui en zone blanche
demain connectés à la fibre optique 158
communes rurales des yvelines vont
bénéficier du très haut débit d'ici à
2022 un réseau déployé par le groupe tdf
une entreprise choisie par le conseil
départemental l'opérateur industriel va
investir 120 millions d'euros sur fonds
propres dans la construction des
infrastructures dans un premier temps
donc on repère peu appel et les noeuds
de raccordement optique
ensuite on met des armoires de rue on
connecte tout ça en fibre optique
on passe par nos propres fibres optiques
con qu'on tire dans l'est dans les fours
eux dans avec les permissions donc de
voirie il n'y aura pas d'argent public
donc pas de l'argent d'impôts c'est un
investisseur privé que nous avons trouvé
tdf qui va porter cet investissement en
zone blanche
une fois déployé tdf commercialisera son
réseau auprès des fournisseurs d'accès à
internet
bré 210000 prise optique vont être
installés dans les maisons mais pas
seulement
il ya également parmi les habitants
énormément d'auto entrepreneur dans qui
sont disséminés dans l'avenir
ce qui fait que
pour eux ce sera un très très gros
avantage que la fibre passe à leur porte
ça va permettre à la population d'avoir
un confort dans ce cas la connexion
internet beaucoup plus appréciable et
surtout ça va permettre au développement
économique de pouvoir vraiment s'ancrer
dans des territoires qui sont un petit
peu plus éloignés des zones très urbaine
la fin du déploiement du réseau dans les
communes du perray-en-yvelines et de
cheuvreux est prévue au premier semestre
2010 9 en cas de retard tdf sera dans
l'obligation de payer des pénalités
il se tient tous les deux ans le congrès
départemental du secours populaire
français des yvelines est au programme
ce samedi c'est du côté de manque la
ville
il dresse le bilan des activités 2015
2017 et prépare la prochaine mandature
au niveau local de l'association qui je
le rappelle agit contre la pauvreté et
l'exclusion bonsoir pascal rodier
distincts êtes le secrétaire général de
la fédération des yvelines du secours
populaire français vous allez donc mener
ce rendez vous samedi un congrès
symbolique puisqu'il se déroule en
pleine année à des 50 ans de la
fédération des yvelines du secours
populaire français
oui effectivement on a été créé en
février mars 1967 au moment du
redécoupage administratif de la france
en fait alors je vais pas vous demander
de dresser un bilan des 50 ans de la
fédération à des yvelines dans le
département voilà de la fédération
lilloise du secours populaire une
question juste le secours populaire
français at il eu un rôle primordial un
rôle important dans les yvelines
est ce qu'ils continuent d'avoir ce rôle
aujourd'hui je pense que pour les plus
de 6000 plus de 6000 personnes aidées au
niveau alimentaire à l'année on peut
considérer que c'est un rôle important
peut-être un peu méconnu du grand public
encore que on est présent quand même
dans 24 villes du département
ça anime quasiment toute l'année 1600 à
1800 bénévoles donnent comme ça brasse
quand même un petit peu de monde et on
garde une grosse activité sur l'aide
alimentaire mais aussi sur l'accès aux
loisirs aux vacances
on a même des projets de solidarité
internationale donc l'activité
généralistes c'est peut-être ce qui
attire encore un peu toutes les
générations ont fait au secours
populaire
on va parler du bilan de ses activités
dans un instant aujourd'hui si l'on
devait avait présenté le secours
populaire français dans les yvelines les
secours populaire français dans les
yvelines c'est un siège qui est située à
trappes et donc il ya plusieurs antennes
et comités locaux sont répartis dans les
yvelines
c'est ça donc 24 structures locales ou
au total alors sans rentrer dans notre
cuisine interne on distingue comité
antenne en fonction du statut juridique
des différentes structures pour le grand
public ça change pas grand chose au
niveau de la mise en oeuvre des actions
après sur le terrain c'est des
structures qui sont ouverts toute
l'année
d'accord et qui pratique une solidarité
généralistes souvent matériel mais qui
ces dernières années aussi la suisse
diversifier en proposant de
l'accompagnement administratif de l'aide
aux devoirs dans certains endroits de
l'alphabétisation
ça dépend en fait un petit peu de des
compétences qui que les bénévoles nous
apporte dépit de la demande aussi du
public
vous disiez tout à l'heure 1600
bénévoles sur le département des
yvelines oui c'est ça avec des niveaux
de fréquences
variable mais on en dénombre ce nombre
là alors j'en ai dit de mon introduction
au congrès départemental du secours
populaire des yvelines c'est ce samedi
concrètement à quoi sert un congrès
départemental ça sert à préparer le
congrès national africain aura lieu à
fin novembre c'est ça sera le 24 au 26
novembre à bordeaux cette année est donc
en fait si vous voulez le niveau fédéral
c'est le niveau intermédiaire entre le
national et le local a précédemment à
notre congrès départemental se sont tenu
des rencontres de collecteurs dans les
rencontres de bénévoles dans les
antennes locales d'accord et des
assemblées générales de comités locaux
où ils font à peu près le même travail
que qu'au niveau départemental mais sur
une focale plus plus resserré et donc à
tous les niveaux de l'association
renouvelle les instances de direction
et puis on échange sur des thèmes
communs du local au niveau national en
fait pour que la parole soit collective
et qu'on détermine tous ensemble nos
orientations au renouvellement de ses
instances départementales pascal rodier
vous êtes le secrétaire général de la
fédération yvelinoise du secours
populaire français depuis 2001 vous êtes
vous avez fait donc huit mandats à la
tête de secours populaire d éviter ce
que vous êtes candidat pour un nouveau
mandat pour y revenir pour deux ans oui
mais qu'est ce qui vous a poussé wave ou
le devoir encore inachevé vous voulez
mener encore des projets non je pense
que de toute façon quand je il arrivera
bien un jour je ne serai plus là et le
secours populaire continuera d'exister
forte forte heureusement simplement les
instances se renouvelle à des degrés et
des rythmes différents
d'accord notre secrétariat départemental
donc les bénévoles qui m'assiste au
quotidien quand même pour l'ensemble de
l'animation de l'association il ya
quatre nouveaux membres qui vont nous
rejoindre c'est une direction collégiale
à 15
un comité départemental à 40 donc moi je
suis juste un porte parle en fait voilà
donc ça servira aussi ce congrès a
dressé le bilan des deux dernières
années
sur le plan des activités même si on ne
peut pas rentrer dans le détail on n'a
pas le temps
dans cet entretien mais quel bilan
peut-on dresser quelques événements
marquants finalement sur ces deux
dernières années dans le secours
populaire des villes moi je vais essayer
d'aller assez vite juste quand même noté
il ya 10% d'augmentation du public
accueilli dans les permanences d'accueil
donc ce qui ce qui est quand même en
deux ans relativement significatif on a
une progression de la générosité des
donateurs
d'accord on a su multiplier des
initiatives de collecte un peu
originales notamment parce qu'on fait
partie d'un réseau national qui permet
un petit peu d'innover sur c'est sur ces
sujets là donc les collectes de dons par
sms récemment pour les victimes de
l'ouragan irène on peut citer aussi une
opération code barre avec une enseigne
la grande un style de la grande
distribution au moment de noël
et puis on a nos paquets cadeaux dans
les appareils dans donnant dans
plusieurs antennes et cette année on a
fait nos premiers villages d'enfants
copains du monde on accueillait des
enfants du portugal et de graisses ainsi
que une dizaine d'enfants des yvelines
tout ce petit monde là s'est retrouvé
sur la base de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines et on souhaite prolonger
dans les années à venir ses modalités
d'échangé de développement de la
solidarité avec les enfants
là vous parlez des années à venir
justement quelles sont vos perspectives
là pour les deux prochaines années
nos perspectives elles sont
parfois de trouver des locaux
ou des renouvellements de locaux c'est
le cas sur elancourt j'entende elle qui
avait lé l'élection du nouveau président
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
on a une petite incertitude quand même
sur le devenir des locaux à partir du 31
décembre on a pas d'issue en fait
puisqu'on est censé quitter les locaux
qui qui nous sont mis à disposition par
la communauté d'agglo de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines basée à
trappes on le rappelle le siège
départemental mail à l'antenne dès
l'antenne d'elancourt d'accord il est
situé dans la zone des quatre arbres et
donc il ya des travaux qui sont
programmés et nos bénévoles là c'est la
plus grosse antenne du département il ya
pour l'instant pas d'alternative
bon bah ça se produit quand même dans
quelques endroits du département donc
c'est un type difficultés que nous avons
malgré tout donc on aimerait essayer de
consolider sa pour que les bénévoles
puissent encore multiplier les actions
de solidarité comme je les dis il ya le
les activités villages d'enfants copains
du monde et on souhaite aussi favoriser
et développer l'engagement des jeunes
dans notre association est donc on fait
aussi un appel à la jeunesse pour
rejoindre l'association n'y a pas que
les personnes retraitées qui peut faire
du bénévolat dans les associations de
solidarité
merci pascal rodier d'avoir une connerie
je rappelle secrétaire général de la
fédération à des yvelines du secours
populaire français vous tenez samedi à
mantes la ville votre congrès
départemental je rappelle également que
vous pouvez venir en aide au secours
populaire français dans ses actions de
lutte contre la pauvreté et l'exclusion
fait un don sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
retour au week-end dernier maintenant la
grande loge féminine de france et sa
grande maîtresse était à guyancourt
c'était dans le cadre d'une conférence
publique intitulée l'engagement
maçonnique au féminin 450 loges
féminines existent dans le monde et
partagent les mêmes idéaux que
l'obédience masculine à savoir mieux
comprendre l'humain et le fonctionnement
du monde sujet de nicolas d'andry et au
rayon des symboles maçonniques une
lumière tamisée
c'est dans ce temple à guyancourt que la
grande maîtresse de la grande loge
féminine de france est intervenu devant
une assemblée exclusivement féminine ça
ne veut pas dire pour autant qu'on est
entre les angles loin de là 1 on n'est
pas pour autant
je veux dire des femmes qui vont dire on
vit entre femmes c'est pas ça c'est pas
ça du tout mais on a besoin puisque on
est dans une société dans laquelle on
vit en mixité du moment où on est juste
que l'on en mer eh bien il ya des
moments où on a envie de se retrouver
spécifiquement entre nous pour réfléchir
travailler avant de retourner dans la
société mixte créée en 1945 la grande
loge féminine de france compte quatorze
mille membres à travers le monde qui se
réunissent pour des réflexions
philosophiques ou bien encore pour
débattre de sujets de société
marie thérèse besson avait répondu à
l'invitation de la loge
saint-quentinoise concordance c'est
surtout pour faire connaître la franc
maçonnerie
parce que il ya beaucoup de cas eu
beaucoup de gens se posent des questions
dessus et puis pour si jamais des fans
veulent venir nous rejoindre
voilà c'est surtout pour ça actuellement
la loge concordance compte une vingtaine
de membres
le week-end dernier toujours armanet
était de retour pour sa 15e édition ce
rendez vous de l'art contemporain
organisée par le lions club de montigny
le bretonneux a réuni à des artistes
français mais aussi venus de pays à
voisins pour la bonne cause les arrêts
ge et nicolas d'andré des poules en
papier mâché des fleurs à l'aquarelle et
des sculptures étonnantes
bienvenue à la 15ème édition darmanin
ils sont cette année une cinquantaine
d'artistes à avoir exposé leurs oeuvres
les 14 et 15 octobre à la ferme du manet
de montigny le bretonneux
en fait ce sont différents types de
matériaux
il ya des encres il ya des pigments
naturels
il ya des poudre de marbre il ya des
poudres de
du graphiste l'exposition attire depuis
deux ans des artistes internationaux
c'est le cas de christophe qui vient
pour la première fois présenté
l'allemagne et ses régions à travers ces
travaux je viens de kirsten c'est une
ville entre cologne et dortmund en
allemagne dont qui est vraiment au
milieu d'une forêt dans la région du
sauerland qui est vraiment très verte et
il ya beaucoup de nature autour de notre
ville ce rendez-vous pour les amateurs
d'art contemporain est aussi un moyen de
récolter des fonds pour venir en aide à
des associations
donc toutes les sommes sont reversés
pour des associations qui sont au niveau
de la maladie d'alzheimer
le handicap ou la maltraitance pour
information dans l'année dernière par
exemple nous avons eu un résultat de 4
mille euros c'est 4000 euros sont
entièrement reversés à ces
manifestations la pour cette quinzième
édition l'organisation du lion's club
récolte près de 6000 euros
enfin vous la connaissez sans doute la
forêt départementale de ste apolline
c'est un véritable poumon vert de 300
hectares à cheval sur les communes de
neauphle-le-château et de plaisir mais
savez vous d'où vient le nom de cette
forêt la réponse avec maxime le maine
pour le conseil départemental des
yvelines à cheval entre plaisir et
neauphle-le-château la forêt de sainte
apolline et l'un des espaces naturels
sensibles gérée par le conseil
départemental des yvelines
savez-vous d'où vient son nom au xiiie
siècle des moines bâtir une chapelle en
l'honneur de sainte apolline martyrs
dont la mâchoire auraient été brisées et
les dents arrachées par des païens lors
d'une émeute en egypte au troisième
siècle son patronage est directement
liée à ses souffrances
elle est en effet la patronne des
dentistes est invoquée pour guérir les
maux de dents la chapelle aurait abrité
une partie de ces reliques un vecteur
d'attractivité pendant plusieurs siècles
pour les pèlerins détruites au xviiie
siècle
son emplacement est marquée par une
allée de city hull plantés au xixème
siècle est encore visible aujourd'hui la
forêt de sainte apolline est remarquable
pour son patrimoine historique et
naturel pour le découvrir en s'amusant
rendez vous sur sortie retirer yvelines
point fr où vous pourrez télécharger un
questionnaire cap énigme
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal je vous
rappelle l'une des informations
importantes de cette édition on
connaîtra ce soir le nom du nouveau
président de saint quentin en yvelines
les élus se réunissent ce soir en séance
extraordinaire du conseil communautaire
ils doivent élire à bulletins secrets le
successeur de michèle losier qui a dû
pour rappel démissionné après avoir été
désigné seniors sénateurs il présidait
saint quentin en yvelines depuis 2014
sauf grande surprise pressenti au poste
jean michel fourgous le maire
d'elancourt a été choisi comme candidat
de la majorité de droite après une
primaire interne qui s'est déroulée il
ya quelques jours
ce journal vous pouvez bien sûr le
retrouver en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 vendredi vous avez rendez vous avec
le 7-8 l'hebdo de nicolas à kirilow vite
et nous on se retrouve lundi pour une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv 78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]